all right
on 26th of February 1979 Queen Elizabeth
II officially opens Dubai's first
skyscraper it is the Sheikh Rasheed
Tower later known as the Dubai World
Trade Center visualpolitik community at
the time it was the tallest tower in the
whole of the Middle East the amazing
thing but it was erected in the middle
of the desert in a place where as you
can see it wasn't much of anything so
the operation didn't seem to make much
sense nevertheless it was quite a
statement of intent with 39 flaws and at
184 meters that's over 600 feet high
this skyscraper made clear the
intentions of the new Dubai that was
beginning to take shape to become a key
Center for business in the Middle East
that was the goal today five decades
later that dream has come true
Dubai has become one of the greatest
examples of transformation development
and economic success in history and note
these are not just words these days this
Emirate city is home to the world's
tallest building the largest shopping
mall on the planet some of the most
luxurious hotels are one of the largest
international airports a world-scale
megaport and nearly 400 skyscrapers that
means that since the Dubai World Trade
Center opened Dubai has built nearly 10
new skyscrapers every year and that's
not all Dubai also tops the list for
having the most super tall skyscrapers
in the world that is Towers over 300
meters or 900 feet tall no other City
even comes close and above all it has
become a real magnet for attracting
tourists companies and businesses from
all over the world and if Dubai's
history is dazzling Singapore's is not
far behind
this city-state is one of the richest
most prosperous and successful
metropolises in the world in the last
six decades and despite having fewer
than 6 million inhabitants it has gone
from being a poor place to becoming an
important Financial Industrial and
Commercial Center as a result Singapore
has become one of the wealthiest and
most developed countries in the world in
terms of GDP per capita and excluding
microstates the IMF ranks it as the
fourth richest country on the planet
we're talking about an estimated GDP per
capita for 2023 of more than 90 thousand
dollars and take note because this city
despite its tiny size has one of the
best equipped Armed Forces on the planet
for example Singapore has more fighter
planes than the air forces of countries
such as Canada Sweden or the Netherlands
crazy whichever way you look at it the
figures of these two metropolises are
incredible in fact the globalization and
world cities research Network ranks them
as no less than two of the nine most
influential and economically significant
cities in the world they are only one
step behind New York and London the two
great world capitals look at this
[Music]
that reason here on visualpolitik we've
already told you in several videos how
Dubai and Singapore managed to take off
and become real economic commercial and
financial Rockets basically we're
talking about two cities that became
kind of company cities in fact it is no
coincidence that the airports of these
two cities rank among the busiest
worldwide for instance in 2019 the last
year before the pandemic Dubai airport
moved 97.3 million passengers and
Singapore moved 68.3 million you will
see that this is no accident as it
happens we failed to notice one of the
crucial elements of this whole process
the conversion of the governments of
these two cities into true entrepreneurs
and the question is to what extent was
government entrepreneurship important in
the growth and development of these two
major economic hubs what exactly are we
talking about when we say that the
governments of these cities were truly
entrepreneurial can the model that has
been so successful in Dubai and
Singapore be exported to other less
wealthy places visualpolitik community
in this second video of the series we
are preparing collaboration with Harvard
International review We answer all these
questions we'll leave you more
information in the links in that
description so without much further Ado
let's get started foreign
[Music]
from the desert to the world
in 1997 Muhammad alabar former director
general of the Department of Economic
Development of Dubai was given an
assignment to found Emma properties
today one of the most recognized and
most visible brands in all of Dubai its
name is everywhere and that's hardly
surprising given the fact that it is the
developer that has carried out the
largest projects in this city the
development of downtown the Burj Khalifa
the Dubai Mall Dubai Marina and many of
the luxury hotels we're talking about a
company that has developed most of the
projects that have shaped the current
Dubai practically everything that is
characteristic of this city has been
promoted by Mr but who is behind this
developer well as many of you can
imagine the commission to start up this
company came from the government of the
Dubai Emirate itself the same government
that in 2000 listed the company on the
local Stock Exchange and that currently
still controls almost 30 percent of a
company that over the years has become a
multinational today IMR has activities
in a lot of different countries thanks
to which it had a net profit of almost 7
billion was in 2022 but of course the
company's Crown Jewel remains Dubai a
city where projects keep coming one of
its latest major projects is precisely
the development of Dubai Creek Harbor a
huge new District that in the coming
years is sure to become one of the
city's major attractions incidentally
most of the government's participation
is channeled through ICB the Investment
corporation of Dubai the investment
muscle of the Dubai government which in
addition to Mr controls or has
investments in many many other companies
in fact the Investment corporation of
Dubai has had a lot to do with the
success of this city
so you see we are talking about an
investment arm of the government that
controls assets worth more than 300
billion dollars it owns or has stakes in
many of the main local companies such as
the Emirates NBD bank the Dubai Islamic
Bank the airlines Emirates and fly Dubai
along with the developer imar which we
have already mentioned as well as more
than 60 companies in which it has total
or partial Stakes so where does the
money they invest come from well
basically from issuing debt reinvesting
profits and public account surpluses but
the most interesting thing is that over
the years the government of Dubai has
used this partnership to promote
business in the city or to cover those
areas that are important for General
development yet it did so following a
strict Market policy the company's
participating or promoted had to and
have to be competitive not only in Dubai
but they must be able to compete in the
international market this would generate
sufficient profits to enable this
vehicle to continue investing in new
projects a good example is the case of
Emirates
[Music]
it is clear that in 1979 when the Dubai
World Trade Center was inaugurated Dubai
had a clear problem it was isolated from
the world who would want to make a long
journey to reach such an inhospitable
place however if you want to become a
financial tourist and Commercial Center
you need one thing Communications to
solve this problem in March 1985 the
Emirate of Dubai created Emirates an
airline that would revolutionize
InterContinental Air transport and make
this city Emirate one of the best
connected enclaves on the planet it
doesn't matter if you want to fly to
Tokyo Sydney or London in Dubai you
always have connections to achieve this
in early 1985 the Dubai government gave
British entrepreneur Maurice Flanagan 10
million dollars and as many
administrative facilities as possible
his goal to launch an airline in five
months that had to perform well and make
money there would be no subsidies or
Extra Protection the company had to fly
excuse the pun on its own and boy did it
deliver
[Music]
today Emirates is one of the largest and
most profitable airlines in the world it
operates in 148 airports around the
world and in 2022 despite the industry
still reeling from the effects of the
pandemic it earned almost three billion
dollars but above all Emirates has made
Dubai one of the best connected places
in the world this has made it easier for
workers entrepreneurs investors and of
course tourists to come to this city
take a look
August 7 2023 Dubai welcomes over 8.55
million visitors in six months
surpassing pre-pandemic levels and so
along with special economic zones low
taxes and legal certainty Dubai's
success has another key ingredient the
entrepreneurial Spirit of its government
the key word here is entrepreneurial not
to create inefficient and elephantine
state-owned companies but to promote the
creation of companies that while
promoting the local economy need to make
money and be very competitive whatever
the cost but that's not even all the
idea of the entrepreneurial State goes
much further in Dubai the vast majority
of projects go ahead if they are likely
to be profitable and the government also
supports private companies for example
one of its latest initiatives has been
to launch a fund of almost 300 million
dollars to encourage 1 000 technology
startups to set up in Dubai so as you
can see we could almost say that this
Emirate City functions more like a
company than a conventional government
and certainly today its success is
undeniable of course this is not a
unique case Singapore's success also has
a lot in common with Dubai's let's check
it out
[Music]
the city of Merlion
foreign
1942 the Japanese took control of the
British Enclave of Singapore it is a
strategically located city which the
British Empire had turned into an
important Naval base and which suffered
greatly during the second world war well
by the end of that war this city was a
disaster the damage suffered was
enormous many if not most infrastructure
was destroyed and mortality violence and
Corruption rates were Sky High Singapore
was a very poor City where virtually no
one in their right mind would want to
live and you know what the future didn't
look much better as it turned out the
Korean War and the global demand for tin
and rubber made things better and
Singapore regained its role as a trading
Port but little else there was even the
threat of a Communist Revolution in the
city in 1958 the city achieved full
autonomy and in 1963 after declaring its
definitive independence from the British
Empire it was integrated into Malaysia
however things did not work out in 1965
the Malaysian Federation threw Singapore
out and so the country would begin its
Journey alone which was not particularly
optimistic Singapore was basically an
impoverished island with no natural
resources it did not even have enough
drinking water to supply its population
water had to be imported from Malaysia
these days of course things are totally
different over the following 60 years
Singapore experienced an unprecedented
boom that has led it to become the
fourth richest country in the world a
tremendously prosperous place with one
of the highest standards of living on
the planet of course as we've already
told you on visualpolitik openness to
foreign investment a high level of legal
certainty relatively low taxes and a
clear vocation for savings were key
elements however Singapore's success has
also had another ingredient as we've
seen in the case of Dubai the government
of Singapore also had a clear
entrepreneurial calling in 1974 the
Singapore government founded temasek a
kind of sovereign wealth fund or
investment arm that today manages assets
worth almost 300 billion US dollars that
is more than 50 000 US dollars per
citizen the most curious thing however
is that the Singapore government created
this financial vehicle to bring together
state-owned companies and to keep
politicians and civil servants away from
them the idea at the time was that the
35 companies owned buy or receiving
participation from the state would
function as true private companies even
though they still belonged to the state
that was the beginning but then with
reinvested profits they started
investing in new businesses to fuel
their growth up until 2002 temasek
concentrated the vast majority of its
investments in Singapore but then they
started investing in the rest of the
world particularly in Asia the idea is
that these investments in foreign
companies created or strengthened
corporate ties with Singapore itself for
example almost a quarter of all their
Investments are in China as it turned
out over the years temasek not only made
it possible to professionalize
state-owned companies but it has also
become a huge piggy bank for the
government and has helped to propel a
lot of new companies especially in
sectors considered strategic for the
city do you remember what we said about
Emirates before well something similar
happened in Singapore tamasec is the
largest shareholder of Singapore
Airlines holding 55 of the shares with
its help this Airline not only connected
Singapore with the rest of the world but
also became one of the most reputable
Airline lines and what is even better is
that it also became one of the most
valuable and profitable Airlines on the
planet the estimated profit for 2023 is
close to 2 billion US Dollars and the
same could be said of many other
companies visualpolitik viewers with
these kinds of strategies both Dubai and
Singapore achieved several objectives
firstly they filled some important gaps
such as Communications secondly they
contributed to the professionalization
of state-owned companies one of the
tragic illusions that many countries of
the third world entertain is the notion
that politicians and civil servants can
successfully perform entrepreneurial
functions it is curious that in the face
of overwhelming evidence to the contrary
the belief persists thirdly they helped
boost and develop a lot of economic
sectors which in turn attracted a lot of
foreign companies and Professionals in
other words by themselves these
investment arms have driven and still
drive a lot of foreign investment
and last lastly they have created a huge
piggy bank that generates billions of
dollars in profits each year and don't
forget that we are talking about two
relatively small territories Dubai has a
population including All Foreign
Professionals of only about 3.5 million
people Singapore in contrast about 5.5
million and yet the numbers we are
looking at are formidable not
surprisingly in addition to creating
these investment arms both governments
opened their doors wide to foreign
companies and promoted entrepreneurship
like there was no tomorrow so the
question we can ask ourselves is could
this same model be replicated to help
develop much poorer regions would it be
possible to create similar cities in
places like Africa or even Latin America
and remember that this is no trivial
matter for instance the lack of legal
security openness and connectivity
currently make Miami their headquarters
for the Latin American activities of
more than 1 400 multinationals if Latin
America were as business friendly as
Dubai or Singapore it's quite possible
that the vast majority of these
multinationals would not be in my yummy
but in that other city on the other hand
while Dubai and Singapore have built
huge piggy banks that have also promoted
Economic Development Latin American
commodity exporting countries have not
been so lucky of course Venezuela is a
textbook example we're talking about
tens of billions of dollars that were
squandered instead of contributing to
National development be that as it may
at this point it's all over to you what
do you think of the entrepreneurial
governance model of Dubai in Singapore
do you think that formulas like these
could be replicated in Latin America or
Africa you leave us your answers in the
comments and I hope that you found this
new partnership between visualpolitik
and Harvard International review as
interesting as we did if so don't forget
to like And subscribe to the channel if
you have not already done so thank you
so very much for watching all the best
we'll see you next time
[Music]